منذ سبع سنوات فرض الحوثيون حصارا على
مدينه تعز واغلقوا الطريقه الرئيسيه التي
تربطها بعدن وصنعاء وعدد كبير من
المحافظات اليمنيه لجا المسافرون وشاحنات
النقل الى سلوك الطرق ثانويه ترابيه وعره
تمر طريق الحالي عبر وادي السائله وعقبه
هيجه العبد جنوب تعز اللتين تشكلان تحديا
كبيرا امام سائقي المركبات والسيارات
وتودي بحيات عشرات الضحايا سنويا في حوادث
انزلاقات فضلا عن قطع الطريق وانسدادها
لايام امام حركه السير بسبب ضيقها وكثره
التعرجات والمنحدرات الخطيره
العاب تساعده معنا
على الخط من حفار الموديل الغذائيه تتاخر
من يومين من ثلاثه من اربعه الباب وهو
كبير يتقلبوا والخط جمال
تتمثل القرى والمناطق على امتداد الطريق
ويعاني سكانها صعوبات في الالتحاق بمقار
عملهم او بالمدارس وبالاسواق بسبب صعوبه
الطريق وقله حركه السير فيها
والله الصراحه يعني ازمه الطريق يعني صعبه
بالمره والمواصلات
يعني اذا نسينا نروح العمل يعني مبكر من
الساعه 5:30 ما انا حصل لها مواصلات
الطريق بين مدينتي عدن التربه يصل طولها
الى مئه وثلاثين كم قبل تقريبا
ولكن تدخل الصندوق السعودي طالب انه يتدخل
في المشروع فان سحب الصندوق من ال همم
هيجه العبد الى طريق تعز التربه ال- اهميه
طريقه تعز التربه واهم من
بقيه المقاطع في المقابل لجا الصندوق
الصيانه الطرق التابع لوزاره الاشغال
اليمنيه الى تنفيذ مشروع تاهيل وتعبيد
الطريق
الرابطه بين مدينه التربه وتعز وطولها 70
كيلو متر اعتبارها جزء من الطريق الرابطه
بين عدن وتعز
ومع استمرار جماعه الحوثي في اغلاق طريق
تعز الحوبان عدن اعتبارها الطريقه
الرئيسيه تتفاقم معاناه اكثر من 5 ملايين
شخص ليس في السفر وعمليه التنقل في حسب بل
في صعوبه وصول المعونات والمواد الغذائيه
والادويه التي تتضاعف اسعارها جراء سلوكها
طرقا وعره ولمسافات طويله